oh
we're actually seeing this is this ew
this is so awesome is this what haggis
is
why is there a stormtrooper yeah
oh cool because there's no oxygen in
there that's awesome this is like the
reverse of in scuba movies when they
share their oxygen with their loved one
to keep them alive
it's true no you're gonna roll back into
the star line all right cool nice
oh yucky
i love we see the wreckage of the
pleasure yacht
oh is that a tendril of the
this is awesome this has been playing in
my head cannon for years i can't believe
we get to see this stuff now like we get
these questions answered for us
answering it right away oh my god
thank you
welcome back to new rock stars boba
fett's long mysterious escape from the
belly of the sarlacc in return of the
jedi is finally revealed with just a
little puff of breath from a digested
stormtrooper and a blast of a
flamethrower and here we are i mean
after all this who can blame our best
guard covered absolute unit for double
dipping in that back to tank especially
if it stuffs our stockings with prequel
flashbacks and who are those proud
moisture farmer raiders what was their
gang sign was it orabesh for wet bandits
we'll find out this episode as we ask
what though what the [ __ ]
we're gonna get that by the end of this
year we're gonna be locked up in what
the best
oh yeah no daylight
this is wikileaks our new rockstars book
above a fed after show and our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
eric voss my easter egg breakdown for
this episode is coming tomorrow but
right now i'm here reacting to this
episode with tommy bechtol tommy
just like my new favorite character of
all time boba fett my clothes will
continue to fit me a little bit worse
and worse as the season goes on it's
going to be great thanks for calling
boba fed
yeah i mean dude that guy is he's
looking great i think tomorrow
morrison's just like get me back to that
back to tank i want to take off my uh my
shirt so i can just show everyone my
progress
you have a lot to be proud of what a
badass i think he's what we call
jacked he's jacked that is textbook jack
yeah for sure i mean that's just like
when people share these photos of joe
rogan jack that's like
it's like a taller rogan right joe rogan
looks like a thumb that someone put
whiskers on with a
that's sharpie kind of commentary you're
going to expect this season on the book
after show with tommy and eric we have
so much to talk about i mean hey this
episode uh kind of kind of a sleeper
right like didn't didn't move the needle
forward too much but like it just it was
like a nice pallet cleanser after a year
of breathless exposition from uh all
these marvel disney plush shows that are
trying to tell like three to four
different story lines god bless these
shows but like here it just reminded us
of that first episode of the mandalorian
but up until we
found out that the child grogu was going
to be in that series remember that
feeling where it just felt like an
explorative
western yeah kind of laundry show and
there was this nice feeling where we
thought this might not really connect to
anything too much and that's almost how
this episode feels i mean we forget once
groggy entered our lives everything
changed right you know it was so
exciting we couldn't imagine what life
was like before that but for like you
know 41 minutes on that first episode of
book of obama that's kind of what this
feels now yeah if you found this a
little slow or boring i hear you but i i
i kind of just like the just hanging out
in the desert with fabreau robert
rodriguez yeah and uh and tomorrow
morrison all scored look with gordon i i
very much enjoyed this yes i agree it
had a very uh martial arts movie feel to
me which obviously i know george lucas
was heavily influenced by
you know when he was making the original
trilogy so i just like there were
several like kind of boss battle fight
scenes they were really kind of well
paced they didn't seem unrealistic for
an older boba fett like he seemed like
he took enough damage he wasn't like uh
as my nephew calls he wasn't op
he wasn't op eric okay that's what the
kids say oh he wasn't overpowered
let's uh remind ourselves everything
that happened this episode so after
dethroning bib fortuna in jabba the
hutt's palace during the mandalorian
season two finale boba fett's back to
tank bath triggers some memories we saw
kamino in the geonosis arena from attack
of the clones the moment he picked up
jango fett's helmet uh as well as we got
uh his sickening escape from the belly
of the sarlacc and after return of the
jedi i didn't know if this show was
gonna address it and boy they addressed
it right away you could say everything
eric you could smell that scene i love
the little details of just making it
pitch black because of course it would
be inside there's no light source it's
right spelling so he has to use of
course his his antenna uh light there's
no oxygen so he has to use the
stormtrooper so he wakes up like on his
last breath this is literally moments
later after he gets devoured and there's
just little just little things like we
don't see the beak of the sarlacc as he
as he crawls out of the pit because you
know that was added later during the
re-release so all we really got was just
from the original version of return of
the jedi just the pit with the with the
fangs sticking out of the sand and you
see one tendril uh laying off to the
side so you know he killed that thing as
he clawed out of it oh he would have if
he if that's how he escaped absolutely
so much about that was so great and you
know i was scouring that wreckage for
any sign of who might be on there who
might have died hey max rebo still alive
got it was that great to see that guy
back he's saying he's not on tour guys
he's on tour
[Laughter]
hopefully omicron doesn't shut
everything down again because man you
got to see this guy live i really
appreciate it max remo is quadruple
vaccinated he's maxed to the max all
right don't worry about that
right into the trunk as the boba fett
lays in the sand he gets scavenged by
jawas and we know that same armor ended
up on the on the sand crawler where cobb
vance was able to get it uh and then he
gets taken uh slave by some tuscan
raiders and then we jump to the present
when he takes tribute from all these
massaspill leaders alongside phoenix
shand and includes a representative of
the mayor played by our improv buddy
dave pasquez
he's like improv legend that we worship
i shook hands with him at a wedding once
eric we're practically best friends
i believe philip and i drove down to
sarasota florida to watch him and uh tj
jagidowski do a two-man show and we all
take a picture with him so there's some
picture of all of us somewhere
bent over crouching this representative
it's already a slight the mayor didn't
come in person and he demands tribute
from boba fett so already we're getting
a sense of a bit of a power rivalry here
that will probably become important as
the series goes on um so then boba fett
and finic shand uh after
basically uh showing mercy to these
gamorrians a decision that pays off in
dividends later on they visit the town
of moscesba to visit the sanctuary
cantina of gorsef whip played by
jennifer beals the twilight
ruler of this establishment uh they rock
out to some tunes from max revo and
fergan don from the band and they were
playing a version of the cantina music
yeah it's like a cool like spanish
guitar version i loved it awesome to
listen to
yeah that was great um and then
afterwards on the other side outside of
the place they get ambushed by some
assassins but you know the fact that
boba showed this mercy to the gomorians
they jump in these guys kick some ass
awesome to see the gamoreans be like
useful you know in a star wars thing we
got a sense of the mandalorian season 2
premiere where they were sparring in a
ring so i'd love just seeing everyone
has a reason for surviving on the show
they aren't just like background
goofballs like they're actually fearsome
and and skilled as they would be in this
world so uh finnick uh parkour's after
them
that was fun that's all i thought
i just was like someone's gonna put a
picture of andy dwight
and michael scott leaping around with
this scene yeah when she throws she
kicks that one off the roof you know he
just fell right into a dumpster oh yeah
with michael scott
but uh she captures the last of one of
those guys and i assume we'll see his
interrogation next episode uh but
instead we go back to the flashback
where boba and his rhodian co-prisoner
uh go to this uh moisture farm and they
see these mysterious group of raiders
who uh put this weird gang sign on the
side of the inside the motion form a
motion for that looks a lot like the
lars homestead but i guess they a lot of
them probably look like that sure which
is pretty functional and practical in
this area they have to dig for water in
the sand uh and then the rodian uncovers
this six-limbed beast a goro badass yeah
i i've tried to find exactly what this
is i'm not sure as of this taping
exactly what this beast is but then he
uh strangles it and he wins the respect
of this tuscan tribe and that's where we
leave this episode but the question
we're going to dig into uh like we're
trying to find some precious water in
the desert was who was that gang of nico
said above a witness raiding the
moisture farm what was the significance
of that logo that they tagged on the
home we have some theories that are
probably going to be wrong but we're
going to talk about them anyway before
we get to that our merch partners at
epic hero shop have just dropped their
newest shirt in the latest obsession
series inspired by the book of boba fett
it is called the hunter it looks awesome
features a legendary bounty hunter boba
fett this shirt is number 12 in the
latest obsession series it started with
this old gym this is a way back like 20
years ago uh and uh it's gonna be sold
out real fast uh and once it is it's
gonna be gone for good comes in a
variety of colors and sizes when you
grab a latest obsession shirt you will
get the added option to write in a
custom shout out that will appear along
the bottom of these book of boba fett
after shows so get on that and check out
that shirt plus all of our awesome merch
options including my favorite shirt
we've released this year strange
entanglement inspired by spider-man no
way home get your hands on that for sure
get all these though at
newrockstarsmerch.com
all right tommy what was our first
question coming out of this episode oh
eric so many questions but coming up
first who the fetch were the tatooine
raiders and what does their symbol mean
yeah was it just a symbol or was the guy
just like trying to get the uh the solid
chunks out of that spray paint yeah
just kind of spraying some skid marks
yeah
and we're reading into it
what is this
reading into something never never what
does it mean
during boba fett's time as a slave with
the tuscan tribe they witnessed this
band of raiders attacking the moisture
farm and yeah it does look a lot like
the lars homestead that luke skywalker
grew up on this was later attacked by
storm troopers in a new hope where you
know uncle owen and aunt peru were left
as charred skeletons one of the most
violent things we have ever seen in a
star wars movie i'm always hoping they
get back to that level of violence but
then this farm gets revisited by rey at
the end of the rise of skyline
scene everyone loves um but uh we have
to assume that most tattooing moisture
farms look like this i i don't think
this is specifically
definitely the lars homestead um but i i
just think it's just kind of a fun set
piece to go back and revisit we uh know
from cobb vance in the mandalorian
season 2 premiere that literally moments
after the empire's defeat during the
battle of endor and return of the jedi
there's a group called the mining
collective that swept into tattooing
towns like mos pelgo and uh in the
aftermath of jabba's death you got bib
fortuna taking over his operation so
there are various criminal elements that
are very much in operation on the planet
the group that boba fett saw wore these
metallic helmets but they were not the
signature blue helmets of the mining
collective that cobb vance had to deal
with these guys uh looks to be nyctos
anikdos are the horn face dudes they
have scaly flesh they're either green or
they have a red orange color to them uh
and you'll remember that in chapter 10
of season two the mandalorian didn't
john and grogu as they were speeding off
with boba fett's armor they ran into a
group of thieves one of them was anikto
but you'll also have to remember that
the nyctos were the primary race of the
group that in the very first episode of
the mandalorian these were the guys who
were holding on to grogu on arvala seven
now obviously not every group of neutral
criminals in the star wars universe must
be associated with each other it's just
like saying
every rodian must all be after the same
thing right that's not what we're saying
here uh this could just be an uh costume
that favreau's wardrobe department has a
lot of so anytime they have to put it we
made too many costumes
you get a neat toe you get a nico you're
gonna need to check under your seats
um and then the nikdo write a strongly
worded tweet and then we have to
be a bit more careful about
hashtags
gonna generalize anymore no it'll be
better than that we'll work on it that's
a work in progress
we've got time to improve
i i value your first draft thanks tommy
i don't want a second draft of your bits
i want robectol you always know not to
judge me because god's not finished with
me yet
[Music]
i was trying to figure out what that
symbol is right it looks like a j and an
l in english of course but if you were
to merge both of these shapes into one
character that was just a little bit of
daylight between the halves of it it
does resemble at least the aurobesh
letter t
if it is i would love if these guys work
for thrawn especially since ahsoka tano
is looking for that guy the the great
lars mickelson villain from star wars
rebels who is now coming back in live
action that's in in osukatano's episode
of the mandalorian she's looking for
thrawn um
and uh he was last seen with ezra
bridger uh disappearing with the pergol
space whales into hyperspace at their
end of their arc of star wars rebels the
counter argument to that i don't know if
a fancy pants chiss admiral would end up
leading a gang of dirty water thieves on
tatooine i don't know if i don't know
why he would care about that
but who knows what is in store for the
future of this character where he has to
kind of pick up the scraps now um we
also don't know if that letter is even a
t
it could just stand for to t time to
move on to a new theory yeah maybe maybe
uh tommy time because tommy i want to
ask you yeah we have this mysterious
gang with their curious symbol we have a
gang of assassins who attacked boba fett
and fenix shand and moss aspa whom we're
about to learn a lot more about and we
have that mayor of moscesso who clearly
poses a threat to beaumont vet are all
of these groups connected are they all
after something different or are just
going to be warring factions on various
sides of boba fett and it seems like
there's going to be some big star wars
secret being hidden with that symbol
so what do you think it is yeah what do
you think is going to be boba's biggest
threat let me let me uh let me answer
her in order i don't think those groups
are connected i think the group's in
most us but i think the the the
assailants in moscow are a
secret police working for the mayor i
think they were hired guns by the mayor
like a gang i'm thinking the mayor is
going to be someone who run who is like
obviously like a crime lord as well like
mayor is a is a title but like you know
they're just another crime lord
so i don't think they're connected i
think the the raiders and the moisture
farm are part of something bigger part
of another force that's heading to
tatooine or or is already establishing
contacting tattooing and i'm not even
100 sure that the moisture is what they
were looking for you know what i mean
like that might be a reward because
everyone's thirsty on that planet
because it looks like it's basically uh
arizona so you know it's
you need a drink but i wonder if there
was something in that house that we're
going to find out uh it was more
important perhaps a remnant from a
kenobi
or uh a remnant from from uh
uh even if it's not the same house maybe
there's something that was hidden there
you know owen and baru weren't stupid
they were just they were just weary of
the uh of the ways of the jedi and the
force and all that so anything they were
the smartest characters in that movie
wanting to stay out of them so so my
question is did they kind of disperse
you know relics from their family uh
throughout tatooine is this a bit of a
treasure hunt or a race to find you know
some some sort of jedi or sith or force
uh empowered secrets that's that's
that's you know i i know that's kind of
me dancing around but it's the season
premiere eric i can't give you answers
in the season premiere otherwise there's
no reason to watch it's fine stop
yelling at me exactly we need to cast
our nets far and wide yes exactly and i
am with you i hope there's some kind of
avengers compound watch that is hidden
somewhere on some tatooine moisture farm
that um this weird
uh spray paint gang is looking for yes
um but no i think i think you're right i
think uh there's going to be a couple
different villains a couple different
threats and obviously the mayor of
moscow moksha's makshas whatever is is
going to be one threat i believe we saw
that character in trailers i might be
wrong um but i think you're right i
think these assassins were probably
hired by this mayor and i think this
other gang is going to be some other
kind of rival threat uh a rural threat
to the mayor's earnest
and i think that rural threat on the
horizon rural jurors these rural jurors
are gonna
declare a mistrial on your ass if you
cross them and i'm more worried about
them um but i i'm excited to see where
this goes absolutely
but i wanted to ask you there was this
moment where they mentioned needing a
protocol droid
uh we don't know where c threepio is in
the universe right now we think he's
working with the new republic
with leia organa maybe with han solo
somewhere yes um uh maybe somewhere on
chandrila right but
the protocol droid that boba fett
mentioned end up being c3po in this
series well uh you know it's not going
to be rey bloody purchase we know that
it's uh it's certainly not uh shout out
to matt barry for doing a wonderful job
as the droid uh i know man there is i
was like i know that voice was his name
i wanted yes i could hear your clem
fandango uh it was uh
that was
i was like god this is perfect i hope
he's in every episode because matt berry
is my favorite what i wanted was that
droid to just pull a toothpick out of
his mouth and then he just transforms
matt back into matt berry and we all
lose our minds yeah bat
dried uh
i go by the name jackie daytona now uh
no uh yeah i
forgot good matt barry for the uh thank
you it's the only impression i can do
him and john madden rest in peace
ah
so
so the uh can't do it anymore uh
so the protocol droid yeah why not be
c3po you know that guy's had his memory
wiped more than charlie sheen uh so it's
like you know you might as well
might as well you know have it be c3po
for one last dance a familiar face or an
opportunity to bring in uh a new
protocol droid that's just kind of fun
you know another maybe like are they all
sassy british butlers like what are she
are all protocol droids you know they
all have the tune of c3po or what so
yeah i think they all kind of have that
attitude right you have paid to us so
you have uh yeah cd uh waller bridge's
character right right now the millennium
falcon i think right
oh something l7
l7 weenie yeah
l 338 yes that's what it was l337 yeah
droid rights forever droid writes for
everything then she was killed and put
in a spaceship
for she was impermanently imprisoned
inside
a starship well uh we'll see who this
protocol droid is i don't have a problem
with him just sticking with matt barry
as 88 because he's standing right there
you can just be like i could try to
learn a few extra languages right you
just let me go to night school
absolutely yes position i could get my
vcr repair degree online now in just
under three weeks
[Laughter]
all right i wanted to ask you we spent a
lot of time with boba fett in the back
to pod yes right uh so what does that
tell us about his
overall health his state of mind i
honestly thought we were going to spend
a lot of this episode in the back
department yeah i thought it was going
to be a lot of flashbacks and i thought
if we just go back to specific moments
and prequels i would love if one of the
splashbacks could have been his duel
with cad bane that explains the dent in
his helmet yeah we'll see if we go there
but why do you think he needs to go so
much into the back of the pod and am i
being too hard on them no would we all
just spend all of our time in a
back-to-pot if we could i mean but that
so that's my question i'm wondering if
this is one to show us that boba is very
very very in tune with his physical
health or
is it that where he knows you know
especially as a clone
you know even though he was a clone that
was uh designed to age normally not
rapidly
uh does he still have
you know
somewhat of a weakened uh constitution
or is it a thing like many of us have
where the bacta is a a source of
soothing for him you know what i mean
like a mental
uh thing so he you know when he needs to
kind of regroup and reset is he's
slightly addicted to the healing
properties of the bacter tank you know
is it more mental for him and is that a
weakness are we getting a character
weakness portrayed by boba's dependency
on the bacter
tank you know or a character strength
like think of it this way it's a bit
meditative for him right and it gives
him some peace of mind so that he can
reflect back on these crucial moments in
his life absolutely i think it kind of
reminds him of his journey and so he
likes to go back there to kind of ground
him to set him straight uh i like that
aspect of it not just because it gives
us an excuse to revisit these moments
from yeah no but i have some other new
uh history that they'll give us but and
that and eric that's just that's just
indicative of you and i you know you're
all about self-care and taking care of
yourself and i'm all about that grind
and hustle he's he's spending too much
time in that back to tank not enough
time at garage sales buying cuckoo
clocks from old ladies and reselling
them on ebay you know
yeah you could make a lot of money that
way yeah you can spend your life in a
back to tank or you can hustle hey i i
think that's gonna be a new meme coming
out of this show i think uh
football players are gonna limp off the
field to be like get me back to the tank
like that's gonna be
we're all gonna wish we had that in our
lives
watching the matrix resurrections i was
like man i would i mean even if they
didn't uh program my mind with uh with
the false reality i would just love to
just gestate in a pot of goo oh yeah
like fade away yeah absolutely for the
rest of my life i think that i there's a
version of me that's my best life 21
2021 made goo boys out of all of us eric
it's no shame in that
i was born a good boy i didn't realize
like you were driving who is your ally
you merely trained in the ghoul i was
raised in it
[Laughter]
um
well
we're in moscow on tattooing one of my
favorite settings uh and this is where
we spent a lot of time in the phantom
menace so do you think we could actually
see some phantom menace callbacks like
your boy wado as you joked about last
week please
maybe kitster anakin skywalker's friend
who in expanded literature i believe
does meet up with han and leia at some
point as an adult uh on tatooine could
we see pod racing again
on in the star wars universe all right
you know what i maybe maybe people are
going to be uh a little bit critical
of me for saying this god i hope not uh
i'm fine with uh
revisiting watto and sapalba but uh i'm
cool with no more pod racing i think we
have enough cool vehicles moving really
yeah yeah i the pod race i love pod
racing i re-watched phantom menace
recently the padres scene slaps i'm all
um you know i like the pod racing scene
but i'm done with it i'm over i'm pod
raced out i'm ready for something new
you know what was that game of ball
those kids were talking about remember
when they said we're gonna go play ball
and never mentioned
they were like the right like george
lucas wasn't like let me specify her
name a new space game he was like the
kids play a game called ball here on
tatooine so
maybe we'll see some of them revisit we
learn the rules of ball there's a whole
episode where that just plays ball
there's that classroom that we saw in
mandalorian season two but just a
tattooed version of that and it's just
it's just a very very scary looking gym
teacher explaining ball to a bunch of
young young children
well uh speaking of that moment uh you
know seeing grogu in the classroom was
uh was a delight last season on the
mandalorian so i want to ask you for
this show
based off of this first episode where do
you think it's going
are we talking grogu we talking no goo
this season i think a child will appear
i did there was nothing about that first
episode that made me
believe strongly that grogu is going to
appear uh i think this is an independent
not independent but this is a storyline
that does not necessitate it
and i like that i would i would i would
like if they made us wait for the return
of grogu to really build it up and make
it mean something rather than just kind
of immediately bring him back into our
lives agreed i think uh we don't need
grogu right now i think this is your
chance to prove that those those first
two acts of the mandalorian pilot
episode could have worked on its own i
know there's a lot of fans of this show
or people watching the show who might
disagree with that who need a bit more
star wars lore but i'm telling you you
just got boba fett's escape from the
sarlacc in the opening minutes of this
episode are you not pleased
that is incredible that is a high that i
will not ever come down from seeing that
uh displayed and it uh is so well
depicted
i don't care if he's just wandering uh
like uh a maximus aurelius style through
the desert being dragged behind some
panthers i i could i could just watch
that forever that's so funny that you
said that that was my exact mental
comparison was like this is like
gladiator yeah yeah uh there's there's a
lot of good happening right now and uh i
assume at some point it will
strongly connect to uh to star wars
canon and we'll probably have some
character come back but for right now
i'm enjoying the ride i'm enjoying
seeing boba fett's change of perspective
right yes he came from this hardened
warrior who trusted no one to uh having
to teach others the value of cooperation
and being able to trust each other uh
especially trying to explain that to
criminals and mercenaries people who
were the most like him uh and i like
that we're flashing back to his time
with the with the tuscans like we're not
just uh writing that off there was a
reason why we saw with the gaffy skick
with a gappy stick in uh mandalorian
episode nine and uh i was curious why he
was dressed up with tuscan raider gear
and now we're actually spending time uh
with him with that tribe i love it like
that choice
i'm enjoying this i've
just being on this ride with you tommy i
don't want to have time
i just appreciate it yes me too this is
i'm having fun already i can't wait to
spend the the first six to seven weeks
of the new year doing this with you
tommy we're going to be back every week
even when there's no boba fett tommy and
i are going to be back talking star wars
with you guys every week uh and uh my
breakdown of the episode all the easter
eggs coming out tomorrow uh and then
chapter two of boba fett's gonna be back
next week don't forget to check out our
many great merch options at
nyrockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea
boss follow tommy at tummy back to
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wookieleeks on podcasts wherever you get
your podcasts thank you for watching and
we we have spoken
see you next week bye
you